annabeth i'm coming to you first on this
your third collaboration with mike what
is it about his style as an actor's
director or the material he likes to
work with that keeps you coming back for
more oh great question both both are are
distinctly mike flanagan his his
material is always high stakes high
drama
psychologically uh curious
and deep and profound and then
the cast and the crew that he assembles
is
penultimate and so i'm always in for a
mike flanagan experience what is the
experience like when he comes to you
with a new project is it a traditional
audition scenario or does he come to you
and say i've got a role that is perfect
for you in this new project i'm working
on uh well because i have done this is
my third project with him um i think or
fourth i can't remember but um because
he came to me with this and he said
absolutely will you do this and i said
yes sight unseen and i never do that i
never do that
but i i just know his depth and his um
so so yes so he came to me with dr sarah
gunning and i said yes i have to follow
up on that so you read the script for
the first time after committing to it
blindly what was the the most exciting
part of the character on first read for
you gosh for for me uh uh it was first
the trauma of having to memorize
erythropoietic protocolia
and having to say it
but
but really it's just this genius world
that he creates that that defies kind of
stereotypes and they're just real
lived-in characters you know
um
i just watched two episodes last night
in the screen and
you know as kristen and i are saying
it's just so
we all
embody these very distinct
people and it's like we're a family and
we truly became one
all right kristen so
clearly a whole bunch of flanagan
regulars i guess what is it the
flaniverse i think that's what people
are calling it
a whole bunch of frequent collaborators
are back in the mix you are new to the
mix now what is something about stepping
onto a set with a whole bunch of people
who have worked together already that
maybe made it feel like a well-oiled
machine or just really struck you
enhance the way that you like to work
well first of all i really value um
the way that my intrepid intrepid mike
and trevor have
really curated who they work with
because they've gathered
mature
talented
inquisitive kind
thoroughly talented people uh on levels
that are generally overlooked actually
when you're working for the most part in
film and television and
because i'm older in my career it really
matters to me who i spend my time with
and so not only was i
nervous to be joining a company of such
talented people but i also all
concurrently had an innate trust that he
had chosen they'd both chosen people who
were
um
just had integrity and so i would i
didn't want to scoop it up and i did
feel conscious that i was the new person
but i also was excited to join a company
what what is a what's an example of a
quality in that respect that you think
is overlooked that you wish you saw more
sets out there
oh
they're honest like in my very first
meeting with them i i had done my due
diligence
about
if people enjoyed working with them and
obviously i loved their previous
projects but they also said oh no we've
we've called people about you and i
valued that because that really matters
it matters to know that the people are
coming together that have integrity and
are there
um for the right reasons and are able to
uh support each other in ways that are
not just on the page
um i thought that was
stupendous and i i
wish it happened more
all right i'm going to start to teeter
into spoilers a little don't worry we're
going to put a big warning up and not
release this until after the show comes
out but one thing i feel like doesn't
get enough credit we don't talk about
often enough is the value of a good
reaction shot and kristen basically
every time you're sitting in the church
listening to a sermon your reaction
shots are telling me something about the
experience that your character is having
so while you are working on this
particular project do you feel the
weight of those reaction shots more than
on other things you've worked on
um
no no i mean because um
because i'm not i don't think any of us
were compartmentalizing it that way we
were there
honestly uh embodying the experience so
the church experience was exactly the
same as any other scene
we were as invested in the way
um father paul was affecting the
community as we were in any other shot
uh so i didn't i didn't find it um
separate from my whole the whole
experience that i had
but i'm glad they're that that clearly
they're doing their job
it's it's a it's very a very telling
component of the show where i did catch
myself during every single uh sermon as
the show went along trying to figure out
how certain people were responding to
what he was saying so it would tip me
off on where everyone would end up in
the end
right
right well actually to that end i think
there's some reaction shots uh from cast
members and characters that aren't in
there because perhaps it would have
conveyed something too early or
something we knew but the audience
didn't yet
um
but it wasn't i mean the whole thing as
annabeth said was just such a glorious
delicious
meal that every moment we were on set
both we were both having hilarious fun
and then also just really able to slip
into the world you know
oh i just want to say perry that i think
one of the the that um kristen's
character is such a ballast for the
whole
thing throughout from beginning to end
her whole journey
it's it's a privilege to watch her story
because as you say she is kind of a
barometer
for for what we as an audience can see
and
you know like
you know it's no small thing as women of
a certain age
so yeah you know dawn prosthetics and
maybe none of us are you know we're
doing the
not so glamorous look
but
but that's also
really authentic and i feel like you see
that in every character
yeah
yeah i agree i have to ask you both
about that
i guess that last-ish scene in the
church in episode seven is that as
chaotic for you filming it as it is for
us as viewers watching it
i mean it was well it was well
orchestrated chaos but it was it was for
sure it was for sure
it was i remembered to at the time um
you know because it was the midnight
massacre since you're not this will be
not you know no spoiler
but we were also
you know was coping and we're
running around with
fluids blood you know all sorts of
different backgrounds
lots of extras and actors and
you know lots of emotions it was it was
a lot of we would come and like grab
each other and say okay we
we're safe we're safe we're safe we just
kind of come home to each other
i have so many more questions i could be
asking you but i have to let you both go
so huge congratulations on the show i
liked it quite a bit and i hope i get to
talk to you both more soon thank you
good questions terry thank you thank you
i'm glad you enjoyed have a good one
everyone